[Music]
[Music]
I'm Lawrence and I'm pretty 8 years old
I'm from Singapore we are handbook and
we are participating in the play life
challenge and we can challenge madness
in person
yes awesome you guys all qualified some
top ranked players from the play - out
so it's all the highest scores and that
people are most active yeah most
addictive yeah so I think we're starting
off the Magnus is going to be commenting
on a game so in general a strong player
live challenge is based on Magnus is app
play Magnus for the course of the last
year the players that you'll meet
tonight have been battling it out on the
app to meet Magnussen person
we have people from all over the world
from as far away as Singapore that have
flown in to the Savannah to play here
tonight
I vote by my best maybe I can get a draw
baby
you already know you're gonna do first
of all I was trying to try to play
quickly and well yes lessons from
he is the highest rated player of all
time grandmaster world champion magnus
carlsen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no and checkmate on the next move
he's done it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like if I serve a father so well I
feel the didn't man as well as that hard
was it worth the trip are you happy you
came
yes I'm happy yeah I just get to play
the ball champion so yeah